[Musique]
j'aimerais vous parler de deux femmes
noires que je connais très bien et qui
pour le coup n'ont pas eu les mêmes
chances dans la vie
la première s'appelle s'y rendent ding
elle est née dans la cité des tarterets
la cité la plus dangereuse de france
d'un père immigré du sénégal et d'une
mère française qui a eu cinq enfants de
quatre pères différents
alors cette jeune sirène ding cache un
petit peu toutes les cases de l'échec
assuré
elle vient d'une famille qui est
considéré comme dysfonctionnelle comme
des structures et avec les services
sociaux de la dass sur le dos elle va
devoir gérer différentes situations
difficiles comme le fait de retrouver un
jour son beau frère en train de faire
une overdose d'héroïne
elle va devoir parfois voler des boîtes
de thon pour se nourrir et puis je vous
passe le moment où elle découvre que son
père est devenu clochard et que son
petit frère est tombé dans le krach
je vous laisse même imaginer la suite
éventuelle tragique de cette gaming des
sites et voilà pour sir anding la
deuxième personne pour le coup alors
elle elle agace un peu tout lui sourit
c'est un peu une ovni elle est bonne
élève elle souhaite faire de belles
études elle sort diplômé de sciences po
paris
elle veut devenir journaliste elle va
travailler un temps pour tf1 puis
devenir présentatrice pour france
télévisions et pour rester dans la
commande y la comédie bardon romantique
hollywoodienne elle va se marier avec un
jeune énarque brillant un diplomate du
quai d'orsay qui va être nommé dans les
plus hautes sphères de la diplomatie
française et puis coup de théâtre on
reste dans le conte de fées elle va
mettre au monde un petit garçon issu de
cette union qui va être blond comme les
blés et puis ah oui j'ai oublié pardon
cette deuxième personne s'appelle
alexandra comme moi en fait moi je
m'appelle alexandra cir holding baldé le
race je suis en fait ces deux femmes
cette diversité cette complexité
ce qui fait que j'ai dû surmonter et
être dans une lutte constante de
stéréotypes et de préjugés
mais aujourd'hui si les médias en ce
sens un peu mon parcours je me demande
pourquoi en fait parce que visiblement
juge mon parcours à normale on lance ans
parce que je suis noir ou parce que je
restaure je tente de restaurer et de
réparer l'auto estime des afro
descendants de par mes ouvrages où mes
conférences ou bien parce que je suis la
femme du consul général de france à sao
paulo et que je suis noir et que dans
les sphères du pouvoir et bien il n'y a
pas beaucoup de diversité
alors effectivement j'ai gagné un peu
jakpot des couvertures médiatiques
j'ai eu la chance de faire la couverture
de plusieurs magazines étrangers
et puis je me suis vraiment posé la
question si mon parcours interroge c'est
qu'on juge anormal et effectivement je
trouve anormal d'avoir dû à faire autant
d'efforts pour arriver là où je suis de
par le fait que je n'avais pas la peau
blanche mais aussi je trouve cette
vérité troublante parce que eh bien je
vois des noirs beaucoup plus talentueux
que moi qui malgré leurs efforts et
l'énergie qu'il met dans leur vie au
quotidien et bien ils n'auront peut-être
jamais l'opportunité de réussir comme
j'ai pu réussir parce qu'ils n'auront
pas eu les petits coups de pouce du
destin qui m'ont permis d'être là où je
suis alors effectivement ce qui est
choquant c'est que je vais dans un pays
de 200 millions d'habitants au brésil et
qui compte la plus grande population de
noir en dehors de l'afrique mais dans
l'élite brésilienne je suis toujours là
seul noir
et alors c'est amusant parce que parfois
le protocole français me demande de
rester à l'entrée de la résidence
consulaires pour donner la bienvenue aux
invités du consulat est très souvent
j'ai des personnes qui me passe devant
comme si j'étais une hôtesse d'accueil
mais même si j'étais hôtesse d'accueil
j'aimerais ne pas être invisible lorsque
je vais dans un club huppé de la ville
de sao paulo on me fait la remarque que
je ne porte pas l'uniforme blanc que
portent les nounous c'est obligatoire
parce que forcément je ne peux 4 la
nounou de mon fils il n'y a pas de
membres de ce club
qu'ils soient noirs et bien toutes ces
petites choses en fait c'est un peu
parfois difficile de se dire que le
contrôle au faciès existe lorsqu'on est
blanc on ne peut pas vraiment se rendre
compte à quel point ce contrôle au
faciès existe malgré le fait que j'ai un
passeport diplomatique et bien je suis
contrôlé encore systématiquement dans
tous les aéroports du monde comme si
j'avais le profil de la mule et donc
c'est intéressant de se rendre compte en
fait que d'une certaine manière nous
sommes formatés par notre plus tendre
enfance par des choses subliminal des
choses qui nous sont inculquées à
travers les médias par exemple moi je
voulais être une mère modèle pacifisme
surtout pas acheter d'armes à mon petit
garçon raphaël et puis ben il a trois
ans et demi il ne parle que de guerre de
tuer l'adversaire de tuer les méchants
de super héros en fait le système est
bien plus fort que mon souhait initial
sur cette parfois quand j'entends que
les enfants issus de l'immigration nous
ne sommes pas intégrer je pense que nous
sommes intégrés
on n'a pas le choix à la télévision est
tellement structurantes nous formate
notre manière de penser et d'une
certaine manière elle est stigmatisante
avec un tas de messages voilée moi je
pense que mon petit garçon est exposé à
des dessins animés extrêmement violent
mais où finalement
il ya très peu de diversité et ceci bien
sûr a des conséquences sur notre auto
estime alors quand je regarde par
exemple le laboratoire de psychologie
sociale de l'université de clermont
ferrand qui a mené une étude sur des
enfants de 4 ans et bien 87% de ses
enfants de 4 ans désigne nous ça la
marionnette noir comme le voleur de
l'histoire seulement l'histoire ne
raconte pas qui a volé le doudou de
simon mais si des quatre ans tout le
monde est d'accord sur le bouc émissaire
et bien on peut se demander
effectivement si les préjugés les
stéréotypes ont la vie dure
donc c'est important de reconstruire
notre société d'élever le débat parce
qu'il ne faut pas oublier que le low
cost a été légalisé l'esclavagé galement
l'apartheid
le fait que les femmes n'aient pas le
droit de voter ou même de porter un
pantalon
il a fallu que des voix se dressent pour
élever le débat sur ces sujets sur ces
absurdités qui pour certains avaient du
sens à un moment de l'histoire et je
pense qu'il est vraiment important de
changer notre histoire d'écrire la vraie
histoire de france qui a pour le coup
400 ans d'esclavagé 300 ans de
colonisation est très souvent les médias
parlent d'une immigration récente des
années 60 mais ce n'est pas forcément le
cas
saviez vous que nous avons une trentaine
de ministres de députés et sénateurs
noir depuis la révolution française
jusqu'à aujourd'hui et bien aujourd'hui
je suis auteure et conférencière et je
tente de restaurer de rendre leur auto
estime aux afro descendants et ça
nourrit l'âme parce que quand je vois
par exemple l'étude de kenneth clarke et
bien cette étude montre que 85 % des
enfants noirs de moins de cinq ans
choisissent la poupée blanche comme la
jolie et la gentille et la noire comme
la méchante et la moche
alors imaginez vous si dès l'âge de 5
ans un enfant noir à une faible estime
de lui même
comment va-t-il se développer dans une
société qui ne va que l'infériorité
d'une manière subliminale de par le fait
que dans les dessins animés bien il
n'est jamais le protagoniste quelles
sont les images mentales que vous avez
qui nous sont partagées par les médias
sur les afrodescendants et l'afrique
très souvent ce sont des clichés comme
faliez à la misère aux épidémies ebola
sida corruption coup d'état excision
génocide
voilà sont en général les images que les
médias nous partagent seulement
l'afrique déjà nous avons encore
l'arrogance de mettre l'afrique 56 pays
dans le même panier s'il serait absurde
de penser qu'un portugais est pareil cas
suédois
et bien pourquoi penser qu'un ivoirien
est identique à un sénégalais voilà moi
lille afrique que je connais alors
malheureusement ces images montrent une
autre afrique qui n'est pas forcément la
plus courante dans nos médias français
et si on regarde bien l'afrique à une
croissance économique plus importante
que la chine elle est de 8 % elle vient
de dépasser la croissance économique de
la chine
donc il est important peut-être de
changer notre regard et de se rendre
compte à quel point finalement la
télévision formate nos esprits et pas
uniquement la télévision mais des
stéréotypes comme le fait d'avoir 100 %
du cac40 déborde pas de des membres
déborde exécutifs du cac 40 qui soit
monochrome blanc
il est important de faire rentrer dans
ses bords des exécutifs de la diversité
pour refondre notre société et qu'elles
soient plus
équilibré saviez vous que le maire de
paris en 1879 était noir severino
deredia comme je voulais dit nous avons
eu deux grandes figures noires dans
l'histoire de france et ses personnages
ont vraiment besoin de rentrer dans les
livres scolaires et pas uniquement pour
restaurer l'auto est il des noirs mais
aussi pour les blancs pour qu'ils
puissent aussi avoir une autre image du
noir pour casser les stéréotypes que
l'on peut avoir dans notre société et il
est important je pense aussi de
connaître des grandes figures inspirante
saviez vous que le frigidaire l'antenne
parabolique
le pacemaker ont été inventés par des
noirs pour n'en citer que trois
saviez-vous aussi que le père des trois
mousquetaires d'alexandre dumas est afro
descendants eh bien je pense qu'il est
important d'analyser d'où vient la
problématique de regarder comment le
racisme a été construit parce que nous
ne pouvons pas oublier que beaucoup de
nos grands parents et arrière grands
parents sont devenus raciste d'une
manière extrêmement ludique on aller
pique-niquer en famille au parc
d'acclimatation où sous la tour eiffel
pour voir les zoos humains
qu'est ce que c'est que ça les zoos
humains bien c'est un souvenir qui
incommode tellement qu'on en parle plus
seulement il y a eu un milliard et demi
de visiteurs dans ces zoos humains à
travers l'europe entre 1800 et 1958 et
c'est dans ces zoos humains que l'on
payait des noirs que l'on avait mis en
cage pour manger de la viande crue et
pour bien grenier et pour créer en fait
le mythe du sauvage
le mythe du cannibale et de ces
croisements entre le singe et l'être
humain est bien même si nous n'en
parlons plus
cette croyance survie dans le conte
l'inconscient collectif et donc il est
important d'en parler pour prendre
conscience que cette absurdité a eu lieu
et il est important de la déconstruire
avec d'autres messages et il est temps
réellement de parler de la véritable
histoire de france et de tous ces noirs
qui sont venus se battre aux côtés des
français pour que la france soit un pays
libre
qu'est ce qu'un français de souche si
finalement les guadeloupéens et les
martiniquais sont français avant les
niçois avant les savoyards avant les
lorrains avant les alsaciens qu'est ce
qu'un français de souche ce que m'a très
souvent me demandent non mais vous êtes
française française qu'est ce que ça
veut dire
alors il y aurait des français et des
françaises français je pense que la
narrative des dessins animés doit aussi
prôné la diversité le vivre ensemble la
bienveillance pour que notre société se
rééquilibre c'est essentiel et je pense
que cela peut vraiment avoir un impact
immense sur la diversité
alors bien sûr notre constitution
interdit les statistiques ethniques dans
le premier article déjà
seulement si nous avons crier à la face
du monde que les hommes et les femmes
naissent égaux et libres
eh bien il est important de se rendre
compte que en fonction de votre couleur
de peau ou de l'endroit où vous naissez
eh bien ce n'est plus du tout vrai et
qu'il est important de se battre pour
que ses valeurs de liberté d'égalité et
de fraternité soient défendus à leur
juste place et une autre solution serait
de mettre en place des quotas
alors bien sûr certains vont me dire oui
mais les quotas alexandra c'est la pire
des solutions c'est humiliant alors
effectivement c'est peut-être la pire
des solutions mais c'est la seule si on
regarde les états unis
et bien aujourd'hui les noirs sont
rentrés dans tous les spectres de la
société même si il ya encore du racisme
aux états unis on en parle parce que les
noirs sont dans des sphères élevé dans
les médias avec un pouvoir économique ce
qui fait que quand un acte raciste ce
produit est bien nous en entendons
parler de manière globale mais
aujourd'hui on a le courage de se
regarder en face aux états unis je pense
qu'il est important aujourd'hui de
comprendre que les blancs pour moi ne
sont pas responsables de ce qui s'est
passé hier avec l'esclavagé la
colonisation pour moi c'est essentiel
déjà de partir sur ce constat les
allemands de ma génération ne sont pas
responsables de ce qui s'est passé hier
avec hitler en revanche nous sommes tous
responsables de rééquilibrer les
conséquences de ces traumatismes et
cette importance est même urgent parce
que si on regarde le parcours est
l'initiative de desmans de toutous qui
après l'apartheid a créé une commission
de vérité et de réconciliation dans
laquelle sans esprit de vengeance ou
sans esprit de revanche
eh bien il invitait les bourreaux et les
victimes de l'apartheid à verbaliser ce
qui s'était passé
je pense que en france nous avons besoin
de cela parce que justement notre passé
n'a pas été nettoyé et il est important
de le regarder de l'assumer et de
brain-storming sur des solutions pour
rééquilibrer les choses alors bien sûr
les noirs nous ne sommes plus là où nous
étions dans l'histoire de france
nous ne sommes pas là où nous
mériterions d'être et nous ne sommes pas
encore là où nous devrions être mais
j'ai espoir comme martin luther king
j'ai un rêve et je compte bien le mettre
en pratique
j'ai vraiment j'ai vraiment envie d'être
optimiste
et de me dire que cette conversation ne
va pas s'arrêter là et je n'essaie pas
d'être une superwoman
mais malgré mon passé malgré mes doutes
encore je n'essaie pas d'être une
superwoman
mais j'essaie juste de donner la
meilleure version moi même et je vous
assure quand on a la meilleure version
de soi même et bien cette version là
elle a pas de couleur
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]